[Music]
a small but growing number of young
women are joining college baseball teams
in fact over the weekend the first ever
all-women's college baseball
invitational tournament took place in
new jersey 29 women took part four of
whom are current members of collegiate
baseball teams that is the highest
number ever
meg oliver is at centenary university's
baseball field in hackettstown new
jersey for us beautiful field there
where to the two-day tournament just
concluded meg good morning to you where
are you there good morning
hey tony good morning over the weekend
the focus was to showcase the talent of
young females interested in college
baseball it was hosted by baseball for
all a non-profit that for years has been
pushing for equity in the sport alexia
george from new jersey was one of the
players here rounding these bases and
she's finally seen her dream come true
it's everything it's the cleats on
concrete it's the sound of the ball
hitting the mitt it's the sound of the
ball off the bat it's just the chatter
and the duck like everything about it is
just amazing alexia george loves
baseball the 17 year old is making
history as one of only six women
stepping up to the plate to play college
ball this year alexi what did you say to
the naysayers along the way who said
girls shouldn't be playing baseball i
would just ignore them honestly i just
would put my head down and keep working
harder and that would be my drive to
be better and show them that i actually
can play made them be quiet after i
showed them how to play baseball you
know what i mean you shot them yeah
it also didn't take long to show her
college coach at saint elizabeth in new
jersey she had what it takes to be a
part of their until now all boys
baseball team well i was very impressed
with her the thing that caught my eye
mostly about her ability level was the
way that she caught the baseball
i believe there were
10 or 11 catchers there and she was in
my opinion the best one at receiving the
baseball
how old were you when you first started
playing baseball i was three three years
old so what happened uh my dad he needed
an extra player on my brother's t-ball
team uh he
didn't have any other players and
threw me in there threw a hat on her
shirt and said get out in the outfield
right field maybe at three that was
actually left field oh left field and
actually she performed better than the
boys so i was uh
you know she did pretty well what's it
like when you see her out there
well you know um
you know you see so many girls try and
they they
sorry i can't
[Laughter]
touches your heart
you're
fun since 1989 only 14 women have played
college baseball
[Music]
in an effort to attract more girls to
the diamond justine siegel founded
baseball for all the mission is for all
girls to be able to play baseball if
that's what they want to do
too many girls are told that they
shouldn't play and i worry if you tell a
girl she can't play baseball what else
what she thinks she can do
more than 100 000 girls play youth
baseball but only a little more than a
thousand girls continue playing in high
school siegel is trying to change that
by increasing opportunities for
collegiate coed play nationwide and to
add women's baseball as its own ncaa
sentient sport you reached out to more
than a thousand college coaches this
year
asking them to look at female recruits
what was the response like
oh it was great we have growing less
over 130 schools saying please send me
films i have coaches begging me
sometimes we'd love to have a woman
player who fits into our team so we have
a lot going on with what we like to call
co-ed baseball even if it's just one
woman on the team for george she hopes
one more girl in cleats at the college
level can help break the grass ceiling
they've been trying to smash since the
1940s her favorite scene from a leak of
their own in the beginning of the movie
one girl got on the train and she
wouldn't leave without her sister
that was my favorite one why because it
promotes
more women to play baseball but also
promotes girls like kit not to get
discouraged
just because she didn't get picked at
first as more women start to play
college baseball what does it mean for
the future of the game i honestly hope
we could get a like a professional
league together i think it's on its way
it's not there yet but it's almost there
for us and i think if the more women
that play college baseball the better
and the more growth it adds to our
program is women in baseball
alexia plans to study sports management
this fall at college and her long-term
dream as she just mentioned is to play
in a professional women's league this
fall baseball for all they are launching
a women's college club initiative
they're hoping it's just the next step
in making women's college baseball and
ncaa emerging sport anthony boy i'd love
to see that happen tony what do you
think of her catching skills i would
agree with the coach i mean she she's
very good uh you know she's framing up
the pitches yeah she's clearly got a
good touch and you know i don't think
girls who have the ability to play
should be denied that opportunity so i
love this organization yeah so she
definitely seems to have the right moves
i didn't know there was a difference
between left field and right field in
terms of i know there's different
positions that part i did know but i
didn't know one is harder than the other
that's what i meant it was confidence on
the part of dad there who we saw tearing
off oh that was my favorite that was my
put her in left foot instead of right
field that was my favorite part of the
story and she is now yeah and the the
exchange between the two of them too
between the father and the daughter was
really nice go alexia that's a great
moment when the dad says to the daughter
you go out there
tells you you can do anything it's also
a great moment when he can't even get
the words out i know that's
part it's so sweet i know that feeling
alexia a game changer i know you do
alexia big game changer we like that